The joe rogan experience,
overpopulation of wild animals
is handled in one of two ways.
Either you introduced predators or
you manage them with hunting. Um,
there's a place in Maui,
in Maui where they are,
um, the Maui has no
predators, you know, and,
but they also have a bunch of wild game
that was brought in for King Kamehameha,
I think it was in the 18 hundreds. They
brought it in. Um, I'm not sure when,
but there's tons of axis deer on,
on Maui and on Lanai and on Molokai
and a couple of different islands.
And,
uh,
one of the things they've started doing
is they were trying to figure out how to
eradicate them from this area.
So a bunch of hunters got together and
they're hunting these axis deer and then
giving the meat to poor people, like
making it free for them. And it's a,
it's a really cool program,
but that's another sort of situation
where you kind of have to hunt.
There's no other,
unless you're just going to poison them
or you're going to somehow or another
capture them all and neuter and spay
a certain amount of them every month,
there's really no other way to handle it.
Yeah.
And I think that's a big misconception.
Like people that don't educate
themselves about hunting,
they're just like hunting is bad,
killing animals is bad and
they'd get on this bandwagon,
but they don't have enough
information about it. Yeah. Um,
and I think people confuse trophy hunting,
you know,
with like they see Cecil the lion
and everyone goes after, okay.
It's hunting is the, is the problem. But,
you know, trophy hunting is the problem.
But the hunters that hunt for food
and that hunt to you know, help the,
uh, the sort of environmental
impacts that they're having.
Like people don't like snow geese. I
don't know if you know much about Snowden,
read that article that you
retweeted actually. Yeah.
They like a nat Geo article
that I, that I posted. You know,
these birds fly in flocks of like 20,
30,000 birds and they land in a
farmer's field and they eat everything.
Everything and they destroy it. And
you know, like 10, 15 years ago,
these populations of birds, they
weren't like they are now. So, um, well,
large scale agriculture is
also responsible for the
boom and the population of,
of deer deer in,
in America,
particularly like in the Midwest
where all the farms are. It's,
what is it a fucking coincidence that
there's all the deer where all the farms
are? No, it's not. My
good friend Doug, during,
he has a big ass farm in Wisconsin,
beautiful place in the driftless area.
Do you know what that is?
It's where the glaciers didn't
pass through. So it's not flat.
It all these hills and it's very beautiful
and lakes, it's phenomenal place.
But essentially he's got the
deer that he hunts and that,
that he and his friends hunt on
his property. They're farm animals,
they're eating corn,
they're just eating greens.
They mean he grows corn and he's a farmer.
So he grows all this corn.
The deer are eating all this corn
and they're fucking delicious, man.
They're huge. So huge. And
they're so, they're so good.
But there's a reality to
a population control. No.
In Wisconsin, they get it because
they're around them everyday.
They're hitting them with their cars. They
see them everywhere. They look. There's,
this is not like the idealistic view of
someone who lives in a city street and
Toronto and is driving around their bike
looking for signs that are criticizing
Kale or whatever the fuck they're doing.
They're not in the real natural
world that these animals are percent,
they don't get it. They don't
understand. Uh, you know,
they live in their bubble and you know,
nothing they don't understand.
Is it a hunter's actually,
you know, we have to buy tags.
We have to buy or licenses.
There were rules and laws that we have
to follow and those fees actually pay for
the wildlife conservation.
And I,
I'm pretty sure it's the
same in the states as well,
from at least talking to
my friends. And it is, yes,
it Pitman Robertson Act and they don't
understand 11% of all the proceeds from
hunting gear go to wildlife conservation.
And that turns out to be
billions and billions of dollars.
It's far more than any
other conservation group,
far more than any wildlife
conservation group.
Our animal activist group and no one
contributes more to conservation than
hunting.
No one cause we want it.
We want it to be there for our kids and
their kids and it's, it's nature. It's,
it's how the world is supposed to be.
It's also this contradictory
thing that seems,
it seems like it doesn't make sense, but
we love the wildlife. I love the animals.
Just because you eat them
doesn't mean you don't love them,
but you recognize them as,
this is a weird way to look at it,
but it is a renewable resource. Right,
and it is also a magical beautiful thing.
Just because of that doesn't mean you
shouldn't eat it. Yeah. I mean it's this,
this disconnect that people have with
the wild I think is a real part of it.
A real part of the problem.
Good luck finding a Vegan in Alaska know
there's not a whole lot of them that
live out in the bush that are vegans,
salmon and they're eating. You can,
you can bring in vegetables. I
mean, I'm sure there are some,
I'm just talking shit. But
the reality is, if you are,
if you're embedded in that world,
you understand it and you appreciate it.
And it's very humbling. I mean, killing
an animal is very humbling. I mean,
it sounds like just somewhat as an
animal lover, that sounds fucking crazy.
It's hard. It's also really hard. Like
when I see a deer come out, I hunt with a,
with a bow crossbow, and I see a
deer come out. It's, I'm trembling.
I have the hair on my
back of standing up there,
these beautiful majestic creatures
and I'm going to kill it. And it's,
it's really, really difficult. And I
don't think that people understand that,
that don't hunt in and then
haven't killed an animal.
They don't understand the respect and
the amount of effort that goes into that.
Okay.